[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous videos uh we have been
discussing
the problem of a beam subjected to
lateral loading
which induced only bending uh in this
video
we are going to make a modification in
that we are going to consider
uh in addition to the lateral load uh an
axial load also
now this kind of a combined load is
going to induce bending
as well as stretching so you see the
situation here
this is our beam we have the lateral
load in the form of this
distributed load qx and we also have
in addition this axial load okay the p
here and the p here it balances each
other out now
again you note that just like in the
previous two videos i have not depicted
any particular boundary conditions
in fact i have not even shown the two
ends so this uh
this general depiction it represents uh
or it covers
various kinds of boundary conditions so
how do we address this kind of a
combined loading
situation so the first thing that we are
going to do
uh here is that we are going to use the
principle of
stationary potential energy exactly in
the same fashion that we had addressed
the previous
problem of only lateral loading so
so going forward what we are going to do
here
is first of all write down
the total potential energy pi which we
understand to be composed
of the contributions from the internal
potential energy
and the external potential energy we
also note
that this internal potential energy can
be subdivided
into a contribution from the stretching
term
or the axial load or the
deformation due to the axial load and
the internal energy due to bending
it is induced by the lateral load
similarly the external potential energy
can also be subdivided into
[Music]
the contribution from the axial load
and the external potential energy
due to the lateral load
all right so what are the expressions
for these individual potential energies
the v internal stretching that is given
by an expression
which i had mentioned uh in the context
of discussing the castigliano's theorem
on deflections in the previous chapter
so i request you to refer to that
before for a beam like this now where
the but the loading or the external load
is given by this
p the axial load is given by this p is
the young's modulus and
a is the cross sectional area of the
beam
this term represents the uh the total
uh potential energy and the total
internal potential energy associated
with the
stretching the next term is already
familiar to us from what we had
discussed earlier
it is simply the n square by twice
e i
integrate over the entire length of the
beam now for the v
external axial uh
we note that this will be basically just
the negative
of the work done by the by the given
axial load
so if you understand that this p
and this p is applied at the two ends
then
all that we really have to write uh is
this p multiplied by the
by the displacement at the two ends
so for this it will be p times the
displacement at the x at x equal to l
and this one will be p times uh
so we have to be careful about the
algebraic sign here so this will be
minus p
if we consider the x direction to be in
this
fashion if we consider our x
for x to be like this
then this will be minus p times
the displacement at x equal to 0
but even though we can write simply like
that
what we are going to do here is to write
this in a slightly
uh deliberately more complicated fashion
and you will realize the benefit of that
while solving uh
problems where the axial load may not be
actually
be acting at the end of the beams rather
somewhere
in the in the middle of the beam okay so
keeping in mind such kind of general
situations we will
write down the uh the potential energy
as
associated with the uh with axial load
we know that this is simply p
but this p is acting uh so so what we
wish to write this is
is in the form of an integration okay
so even though uh so so let me just
write this down like this
so suppose i write it like this
that p times
us evaluated at x equal to
capital l this u s
variable it represents the deflection in
the axial direction so this is the
or the displacement this is solely due
to the stretching term
the s represents that and it will come
with a negative sign
but i'm not going to keep this term like
this rather
i'm going to as i said convert this
into a into an integration form
ok so how can i do that
to see what i have done i have
considered this p
times u s but i have considered
this in the form of an integration but
at the same time i have
made it so that there is this uh
dirac delta function or this direct
delta operator which is
at x minus l so that ensures that this
multiplication is only going to be
really applicable uh at x equal to
l okay next in a similar fashion
i want to take care of this this
this end so for that
what i would do is to write something
like this
okay this minus p represents the fact
that
at this end the axial force is in the
opposite direction of the positive x
sense
now of course we i don't want to keep it
like this i want to make it like this
an integration form so
all that i have to do
is to write the appropriate
direct delta operator
that is x minus 0 simply multiplied by u
s please note that both
in this integration as well as in this
integration this
u s in general represents the
uh displacement uh due solely to
stretching uh anywhere at
uh between the zero and l but it is
because of the presence of this direct
delta here in this direct delta
here that this term gets activated at x
equal to l here and at x equal to zero
here
okay so so much for the uh
potential the external potential energy
due to the axial load
the potential energy associated with the
lateral load will be exactly the same
as what we have discussed earlier in our
earlier video
so that is simply minus
times q w
e x this entire integration
um this integration is from 0 to l
over the entire length all right
now uh you see this term is already
familiar to us
this term is familiar to us these two
things are quite new
plus this is also new okay now
what we are going to do is uh
just like we had we had
considered the
the rewriting of this term uh
in terms of the
the lateral displacement w
which is this w okay so
uh i request you again that if you have
not seen the earlier video
where we had used the principle of
stationary potential energy
on the lateral loading only
which induces only bending you please
look at that first because i am going to
utilize those expressions directly here
okay so the motivation here is the same
that this term which involves the p
i again want to rewrite this term
uh in terms of the
us variable which is present here and
which is present here
in much the same way that this m was
written
in terms of the w which is present here
so ultimately my motivation here or my
final goal here
is to obtain governing equations in
terms
of the deflection variables us
and w right so towards that end
i note that my p
is basically this
so this is sigma xx integrated over the
entire cross-sectional area
and that again considered a very
simplistic kind
of uh material behavior
basically the simplest of material
behavior like the hook and material
behavior
of we have this kind of a situation
sigma xx is equal to young's modulus
times the epsilon
xx and you understand that
uh this epsilon x6 can be directly
written in terms of the stretching
variable
us using the strain displacement
relation
like this please note that here i have
not used any partial derivative
because uh the only thing that
us is varying with is x okay so these
are certain simplifying assumptions
which are inherent
in our derivation
okay uh coming back to what i was saying
[Music]
this is of course d a now this can be
further simplified
to uh ea
us dx the understanding here is that uh
even though us may be varying along x
but over a particular cross section it
does not have
any variation okay so this can be taken
out of this integration the e also can
be taken out of the integration
uh that we are just left with this
integration over the
for the entire areas which is just the
area itself all right
so uh with this we can
proceed and
we can write down the can write down the
uh the expression for delta pi
okay so
this is the part where we are going to
use the principle of stationary
potential energy
so let me just write this down once more
when i substitute
the appropriate expressions so
this is
you understand that what i have done
here basically
is that if you look here
this p is e a d u s d x but i have here
is p square by twice e so when i
substitute this expression back here
this i have e square a squared in the
numerator
and that cancels with this denominator
to leave
e a so ultimately what i have is half of
e a
times this u s d x square
that is exactly what i have written here
okay next for the term involving the
bending moment as we have done in the
previous
uh case up
for the for the case involving the only
the lateral loading
we had seen that we had obtained this
expression
half of e i d square w
d x square i'm not going to go into a
discussion for this again
uh we've already spent some time on this
and the rest of the terms i'll just keep
like that
as before p
direct delta x minus l
u s d x and plus
because we have a minus and then minus p
inside so
it becomes a plus we direct delta
x minus 0 usdx
minus
0 to l q w
close dx square bracket equal to zero so
whatever is there within the square
bracket we have to take the first
variation of that
now you please note that uh
when we take the first when we like when
we do the subsequent steps
you see that this first variation is
going to uh
be operating on these terms separately
now if you consider just this term
whatever is going to happen here
we've already done it we don't we don't
have to actually clutter up our space
here
our writing space here uh by repeating
those
lines okay by repeating those terms
like this one and this one they're
exactly the same as before
all that you have to really do in terms
of new effort
is to deal with this term this term and
this term
so let us do that okay so
so for the first term
what i'll have is e a
d u s d x
then d delta u s dx
dx plus
i'm going to write this as same as
before
because i'll have i'll end up with quite
a few terms here
i don't want to clutter up my writing
space here okay
for this i have for this term i have
minus p delta the direct delta
x minus l then
[Music]
delta u s so please don't be confused by
this delta and this delta t this delta d
is the direct delta
this delta of us this delta is
is this delta which is the first
variation delta
and then of course i have similarly
t direct delta x minus zero
delta u s dx
and
0 to l this is also the same as before
but because this is such a short term
i'm writing it anyway
this entire thing is equal to 0
all right now uh
all that i have not written here it
basically involves
in the in the various steps uh if you
remember from before
a repeated use of
the integration by parts and the
motivation there
was ultimately to arrive at an
integration term
uh which would involve the first
variation
of the of the bending variable or the
deflection variable w
because in this other integration term
we have this
first variation of w which does not
involve any
uh any derivatives so in a similar
fashion
we motivate our subsequent steps of
simplifying this expression
with the understanding that we want to
arrive or with the goal
that we want to arrive at an integration
term we should involve the delta u s
but we should not involve any any
derivatives like this
we want to have a term like this delta u
s which does not have any derivative
a delta u s which does not have any
derivative okay so towards that and we
carry out
the integration by parts so for the
boundary terms
we'll have this uh this thing
ea du s dx delta us
0 and l and then
d dx of e a
d u s d x
delta u s d x so now you see that
here we already have this the presence
of this delta u s
uh which is exactly what we have here
and here
so we write the rest of the terms just
like they're present in the previous
step
all right so uh
what do we do next well uh
we can proceed in different fashions
like for example
we could have uh so
sorry i have not written a very
important thing
which is this term which is the same as
before so i really need to write that
properly
let me do that
so what i'm doing is i'm writing this
plus same as before
okay actually this term
is also should have come under the same
as before but anyway i'm going to write
it separately
all right
now you see whatever is present in the
same as before
is basically just the boundary terms
involving the delta w
uh uh or the w
uh and one integration term involving
the delta w
okay so what we had done earlier was to
club
that integration term with this term to
obtain the governing differential
equation
so that's the same thing what we can do
here is to club this integration term
with this one and this one
to obtain a governing equation which
would of course involve this
direct deltas that is certainly one
version
that we could go ahead with or we could
choose
to write this or obtain a slightly
different
version of this okay so let's let's
let's try this slightly different thing
because uh because if we if we were to
choose
to or to go for the first version then i
mean it's just
very easy and straight forward you just
obtained as the diff as a governing
differential equation involving the
involving the coefficients of this delta
u s this term with this term
and this term so there's not much to do
there
but let's see what happens if we choose
another version of it that will be
really interesting
so what we'll do is
we'll just consider this term and this
term okay so let's do that
we're going to consider this term and
this term separately so please note that
what i'm going to write next
is not the implied sign of this okay so
i'm going to write with a separate color
also
so let's consider this integration 0 to
l
t times dirac delta x minus l
delta u s t x
plus
so this thing can directly of course be
written
because uh at the very outset i had
noted
that this is simply this the only
difference is that back then
uh we did not have the involvement of
the of the
now the first variation that is present
here so
uh the same same thing for the second
term
so that overall this can actually be
written as
in the form of boundary terms okay so
what i was saying earlier uh
is this is basically uh this that if
we were to proceed uh directly from this
term
uh i mean club clubbing this integration
this integration this integration
then we would obtain as our governing
differential equation of
the coefficient of this delta u s which
is this term
and then we would have this t times the
dirac delta of x minus l
and the speed times the dirac delta of x
minus zero so this
the this p and this p would be present
in the governing differential equation
itself
however in this version that i am
proceeding
right now you see what has happened is
that i have managed to write these two
things
in terms of these boundary terms so that
subsequently
what what is going to happen is that
this is going to get clubbed
with this term okay so you take so if
you have
any confusion you pause the video and
maybe uh take a moment to
to realize what is going on here okay
so in this version we are going to club
this
with this all right uh
and whatever was happening before
involving the w terms
that is going to remain the same as
before we don't even have to worry about
that
and in fact i'm not even going to write
that okay it is exactly
the same as before uh i'll just deal
with this terms
involving the u.s okay
going to the next slide uh
we have is
ea us
ex
delta us
this boundary term and we have this
integration term
please note that in the previous slide i
had this
ddx of ea usdx i am considering that e
and a are independent of x
so that in the next step that i'm just
now writing i'm writing this as e a
r times d squared u s d x squared
and then i have these boundary terms
which i have just
derived in the previous slide
plus instead of writing same as before
what i'm going to write is all the terms
or terms
involving w
this is equal to zero
therefore
the governing equations
the governing equations are
e
d square u s e x square
is equal to 0 because you note that here
we don't have any other integration term
uh
i have missed something here
should be with a delta us
now it's right okay so
there is no other integration term which
involves this delta us
had we kept this this term in the form
of the integration then certainly there
would have been
uh and then would have instead of the
zero this p
dirac delta x minus l and a minus p
delta dirac delta
x minus zero but those things are not
present because i have converted those
integration terms into these boundary
terms
so they will be they'll be present in
the boundary terms actually
but let us not forget that these
governing equations
also have contributions from these terms
involving the w
and that we have seen earlier was
this e i d 4
w d x support
and that is equal to q and for the
boundary conditions
what i will have is this term clubbed
with this term
so that i need to write this as at
just like before at x equal to 0
and x equal to l
[Music]
i have
either
e a d u s
d x minus p
is equal to zero or
u s is specified
i again emphasize that it is extremely
extremely important to write this
in this proper fashion okay please note
that because that we have the presence
of this delta us term
it is us which needs to be specified as
part of the boundary but us
itself does not need to be 0.
in addition to this we'll have again
at x equal to 0 and x equal to l the
terms
involving the w so just to make things
clear
what i'll do is i'll go back to the
slide where i had mentioned those
up and point those to point out those to
you
okay so this is what i'm talking about
here right
so uh i had i had this thing
let me see if i can can actually copy
this thing out
so this along with whatever
else was present here
which is this one
okay so at x equal to zero and x equal
to l
uh what i can do is i can write this
slightly more
feeling fashion it's like this
these are our boundary conditions at x
equal to 0 at x
equal to l we have in addition to
whatever we had
earlier in terms of the w this extra
boundary condition
involving the us okay so this e8 usdx is
equal to p
either that or us is specified so this
two bound so these two equations are the
governing equations
and these are the things which will act
as our boundary conditions
so together all of them together they
are
the the desired equations for our
mechanical
system now it is very very important to
note
one critical thing all throughout our
discussion we have
found it very convenient to talk
separately about the us
and the w and this is the hallmark of
this derivation
that uh the the stretching and the
deflection
can be dealt with in a separate fashion
like completely independent or decoupled
from each other okay quite independent
from each other
and this is exactly the uh the the
simplifying
uh thing that we have done which will
which will get us into trouble
when we consider instead of stretching
some kind of compression as i had
pointed out
uh and emphasized uh in the in the first
video of
this beam theory chapter uh that
overview and prelude
of the issues associated with buckling
so this kind of a theory
it will be will be because because this
the stretching
and the and the bending they are
decoupled from each other
uh it will it will get us into trouble
because it is not
going to uh enable us to address issues
in ordering
buckling but we'll see that later so
the idea is that in the next video we
are going to
take another look at the very same
problem that we have done in this video
but we'll address it from the point of
view of the principle
of virtual work thank you very much